Are you new to Monterey?
Yeah, we just moved here.
MADELINE MACKENZIE:
You're gonna love it.
(GRUNTING)
CELESTE WRIGHT: Passion is...
definitely not our problem.
JANE CHAPMAN: Every time someone
asks me about Ziggy's dad,
I'm terrified
they're gonna expose me.
(GLASS SHATTERS)
-(WAVES CRASHING)
-♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
BONNIE CARLSON: We don't want
anyone getting hurt, do we?
-ED MACKENZIE: Hey!
-Bitch.
JANE: Gotta have
each other's backs, right?
Who's got yours?
-(GUN SHOT)
-(BRAKES SCREECHING)
-♪ (PIANO MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
-(CAMERA SHUTTERS CLICKING)
RENATA KLEIN:
These women, they're vicious.
(SIRENS BLARING)
CELESTE: We all do
bad things sometimes.
(WOMAN GASPS)